[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight sometime in the next two
months a group of Democratic donors and
political consultants will call each
other on the phone and decide who their
party's vice presidential candidate is
gonna be this happens every four years
but for the first time in memory this is
a genuinely meaningful decision in
normal elections candidates choose
running mates
whose signature qualities are blandness
and obedience a good vice-president is a
lot like a good waiter
he appears takes orders and leaves he
does not talk too much he does not
express interesting opinions when vice
presidents say they serve the president
they're not being polite they're being
literal it's a service job but not this
year this year Democrats have chosen a
man who can't manage the country even if
he does win his aides know that the
candidate himself seems to know that the
whole country knows it we just don't
talk about it very much Joe Biden's
decline is so depressing to watch so
embarrassing and sad that most of the
time the rest of us try to ignore it and
pretend everything is fine many of us
know that someday we will be where Biden
is today so it feels like bad karma to
dwell on it but the vice presidential
pick forces this issue whomever is
chosen will run the government if Biden
wins once his advisors make that
decision they'll call Biden in his
basement rec room and let him know who
is running mate it is Biden will
practice the name to make sure you can
pronounce it he'll fiddle with the
camera on his iPads and then he'll tell
the world who will it be well it will be
a woman we know that much Biden is said
it so you can take half the country off
the table right away no man no matter
how clean bright and articulate is gonna
share a ticket with Joe Biden
so that leaves nearly a hundred million
American women to choose from and by the
way when Joe Biden says women he'd like
you to know he means no offense to the
gender-fluid gender non-conforming or
indigenous two-spirit communities all of
whom built this country and have Joe
Biden's gratitude but in this case Biden
would very much prefer a lady so who's
it going to be well the Washington Post
has already cast its vote over the
weekend Jeff Bezos his newspaper all but
endorsed maybe the single least
distinguished person ever to emerge from
the Georgia State Senate Georgia
politics in general a frequent Cable
News guest called Stacy
Rooms Abrams lost a governor's race once
then under a pen name wrote some
softcore porn thrillers books that won
Amazon review were noted have a quote
nice amount of heat and that's about the
sum total of it Stacey Abrams his career
has unfolded almost entirely without
distinguishing achievements she does
understand Joe Biden pretty well though
and that's her main advantage Abrams
knows her senses that Biden doesn't
really believe anything he just wants to
be liked and more than anything Joe
Biden does not want to be called a
racist that's his kryptonite this turns
out to be good news for Stacey Abrams if
it helps her get the job she is more
than happy to call Joe Biden a racist do
you think that not choosing a woman of
color a black woman actually is a slap
in the face to the black female voters I
would share your concern about not
picking a woman of color because women
of color particularly black women are
the strongest part of the Democratic
Party Stacey Abrams shares your concerns
about not picking a woman of color
especially if that woman is her she's
very concerned about that turns out that
senator camel Harris has the same
concern like Stacey Abrams Harris
recently lost an election the media
predicted she would win but unlike
Abrams Harris isn't just threatening to
call Joe Biden a racist
she already has I'm gonna now direct
this at Vice President Biden I do not
believe you are a racist but you also
work with them to oppose busing and you
know there was a little girl in
California who was part of the second
class to integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me uh-huh in
the long and ignoble history of the
Gibby what I want I'll call you a racist
politics that has to be one of the great
moments Kamla Harris is so completely
out of touch with American life that she
imagined that somehow forced busing was
wildly popular with African Americans it
was not popular it is not popular now
why because busing was patronizing and
destructive it hurt everyone involved
except maybe for the self-satisfied
white liberals who designed it there
kids went to private school but somehow
Kemah harris didn't know that so say
what you will about Stacey Abrams she's
clearly a lot smarter than Kimmel
Harris's we'd like to see Kamla Harris
right a porn thriller we died would have
any heat at all even Joe Biden seems to
figure this out recently he's been
talking to a new candidate who's neither
one of these and it's Gretchen Whitmer
the governor of Michigan Wimmer
confirmed that yesterday on NBC how's
the vetting process going so far you
being vetted by mr. Biden you know
conversation with some folks how would
you characterize the conversation it was
just an opening conversation and it's
not something that I would call a
professional you know a formalized
vetting a professional you know
formalized vetting okay as opposed to
apparently to an amateur vetting the
kind you don't get paid for what is
Gretchen Whitmer talking about no one
knows ask anyone who lives in the state
of Michigan they're still trying to
figure out why Gretchen Whitmer banned
the sale of paint and carpet in response
to a pandemic Whitmer never explained
why she did that exactly she has no idea
herself paint and carpet just seems
scary to her so she made them illegal
then when citizens complained about this
Whitmer denounced them as racist
do you sense a theme here now what are
the Biden campaign called Gretchen
Whitmer they're looking for someone with
deep experience dealing the race card
we should note there are a few other
possibilities people you may not have
heard of for the vice presidential pick
Michelle Grisham is the governor of New
Mexico Grisham spent her first year in
office fighting to increase the number
of abortions in New Mexico because
America's birth rate isn't falling fast
enough for her D Grisham call her
opponents racist too probably we haven't
checked but you'd have to guess and then
there's congressman Val Demmings she
represents Florida's 10th congressional
district Demmings is not well known but
her appearance is what Biden says he's
looking for Demings was one of the
impeachment managers during last winners
climax to the Russia insanity remember
back when we were pretending Ukraine was
somehow vital in some way huh
remember that whatever nothing else the
job put her on television a lot our
president put his personal interests
above the interests of the nation
corrupt
and cheating our democracy and he shall
be held accountable because you know
what nobody is above the law
cheating our democracy whatever that
means
Demmings is a former police chief good
for her that doesn't mean she believes
in enforcing the law though she says
immigration law should be ignored she
hasn't explained what other laws should
be ignored she's also back legislation
to let police confiscate firearms from
citizens who haven't even been accused
of a crime huh and then finally
lingering in the background like a shy
teenager is senator Amy Klobuchar of
Minnesota now in a normal political
moment which this is not klemish are
might be the front-runner for the job
she did surprisingly well in the first
two Democratic primaries both in swing
states she's relatively popular serving
in a state that Hillary Clinton only
narrowly carried four years ago so she
could help
she's also older she's calmer more
experienced at times she even seems like
she might not be a total extremist all
of which means Amy Klobuchar probably
has no chance at all
weirdly Joe Biden over his 50 years in
Washington was often described as a
moderate and if Joe Biden were still
with us maybe he would be still moderate
today but he's not Joe Biden's handlers
are in charge now they're not moderate
they've moved the poor guys so far the
fringes Biden is now disavowing the
Obama administration for being too far
right Barack Obama movement conservative
it's pretty amusing really also a little
scary